jamie metz is with me now who advisory
committee and sir good afternoon
sorry good morning to you not quite sure
of your location but
thank you for joining us what do you
think about this idea to go ahead and
put out something
um where these two leaders could agree
to find the source for
for how it broke out you heard red
fields interview from earlier today what
do you think
i think we need a full investigation
into the origins of this terrible
pandemic we've needed it since day one
china has been blocking that it's been
very difficult for
people like me and others to to raise
this critical issue but now the
conversation is opening up and there's a
very real possibility this pandemic
escape from the the virus escape from a
lab starting the pandemic
it's still possible there could have
been some kind of
zoonotic jump in the wild that's why we
need a full investigation with
unrestricted access to all the relevant
records samples and personnel
and it's just unbelievable that a year
and a half
after the initial outbreak we still
don't have that what do you think
what do i think mm-hmm i think it's
terrible i think
that there's i mean in terms of the
origin no yeah in terms of the origin
what do you think yeah yeah yeah yeah so
i have this on my jamie metzel.com
website i think it's most likely a lab
incident
origin uh for me the coincidences are
just
too great that this pandemic doesn't
start in southern china where they have
horseshoe bats
but starts in wuhan where they don't
have any horseshoe bats in the wild they
have china's only level 4 virology
institute
with the world's largest collection of
bad coronaviruses
as uh redfield correctly states this
virus
it just shows up on day one ready to
infect
humans and that's very dissimilar from
most of the other
pathogenic outbreaks in the wild that
we've seen in the past there are some
really big questions in my mind they
point toward
but don't yet conclusively prove a lab
incident origin
which again is why we need a full
investigation either there's a split
screen i don't know if you can see the
programming where you are jamie but
uh the president has just arrived in
geneva he's got a little greeting party
there
on the tarmac and we'll see uh after
this point we'll wait for him tomorrow
actually to
uh with vladimir putin um the point
being here that there are states in the
u.s right now that are ready to go 100
percent
open it all up vermont was the first one
yesterday new york is right on the
the cusp of doing this russia's in a
different situation now
is this something where these two men
could accommodate a similar statement to
define the origins you know i certainly
i certainly hope so uh it's in
everybody's
interest to get to the bottom of this
but as you know bill uh
russia and china having an increasingly
cozy relationship and because china is
blocking the kind of full investigation
that we need my guess is putin is going
to be a little bit cautious
about putting too much pressure on his
friend
xi jinping but if that is the case it's
really unfortunate because
everybody including frankly everybody
in china is a beneficiary of
understanding what went wrong so we can
identify and and fix
our biggest problems and build a safer
future for everybody it seems an easy
thing to do especially the people in
russia are still hurting from this
uh dr xi jing li from china i know you
know the name
denying any sort of lab leak saying how
on earth can i offer up evidence for
something where there is no evidence
i don't know how the world has come to
this constantly pouring filth on an
innocent
scientist end quote you saw that yeah
yeah i did see it it's just uh
preposterous what she's basically saying
is we should trust
not just her uh but the chinese
authorities
the same chinese authorities who have
been engaged in this massive
cover-up since day one involving
destroying samples hiding records
imprisoning citizen journalists
they've established a universal gag
order preventing chinese scientists from
saying
or writing anything about pandemic
origins without
prior government approval and if the
question is oh we should just
trust the chinese government really the
same government that's engaged in a
cultural genocide in xinjiang that's
trying to destroy tibetan culture that's
destroying democracy in hong kong that's
doing this great uh grab land ocean grab
in
in the south china sea unfortunately uh
we live in a world where
the chinese government has denigrated
the trust that we that many people hoped
that we could place on them
yeah jamie thank you i hope you come
back soon okay jamie metzel there's a
lot
there's a lot more to go on this and i
think you would agree with that
thank you